hey guys it's Justine and welcome to the
behind the scenes of shooting the macro
unboxing video for this video I wanted
to get really crazy I normally only
shoot 4k we're shooting on three 8k red
helium's we've got Tyler over here Korey
over here Nathan over here I was looking
to get 3a Cameron's basically at a last
minute notice and somehow I managed to
text Nathan over Thanksgiving break it
happened to be at alternative rentals
where we got these cameras that's a huge
thank you to you guys in Culver City hi
thank you for making this beautiful
project possible also got a lot of other
gear happening here specifically for the
shoot I knew it was gonna be happening
so I got a new light over here check
this one out one of the things that I
haven't had forever RC stands any time
anybody comes here to do a shoot they're
like where are your C stands I don't
have any
I've got C stands we've now got some
sandbags because usually I was just
telling people to sit on this here to go
down do these guys right here also a new
addition not rentals these are the man
lights they're great because you can
also switch them to RGB colors which I'm
not gonna touch right now but you can
see an example back here we've got those
set to a nice orange hue of course we
have the centerpiece of his whole entire
video which is the new Mac Pro you've
got the two dual Pro display XT ours
these are the matte versions which are
really great because behind me is a
window so if we were shooting these
weren't the matte ones you would see so
many more reflections it's been a while
since I've edited with this type of
matte display this thing is so insane
I've just been kind of stepping back and
just admiring the beauty
[Music]
this is behind the scenes of shooting
the beauty shots for the maggot burrow
this has been two incredibly intense
days but it's been worth it
[Music]
we're now on our way to rent a slider
because we wanted to get some cool
b-roll shots of the Mac Pro you may or
may not have already seen those you know
we thought we would just go out and make
a vlog
I think I yell lettuce for filming in
there I feel silly Nathan what did you
get us was a big boy what I was
picturing like a small tiny little thing
well that wouldn't work you're right
yeah so we had to get the real thing
well I'll get you some coffee
well going I'm gonna need a new server
if you just wheel it and I'll carry okay
did you tell my carbs you need perfect
thank you appreciate it
I definitely thought this was gonna be
smaller like this the size of the body
[Music]
that's gonna have to do let's get back
to it
[Music]
with dual monitors so this has been a
really great experience because I'm able
to have one of the monitors set as a
completely full resolution of the video
that I'm editing and over here is kind
of like my workspace timeline
unfortunately this isn't my official
setup like I'm gonna have to move the
stuff upstairs we're still in shoot mode
right now so we basically turned this
entire living room into a set we moved
couches Nathan how much total gear did
we write like how much would that have
been if we bought all of this gear
renting is cool you want to come see
where I hid all the mess before we
started filming I realized that
everything was a complete disaster so I
cleaned up a little bit and this is what
it looks like
cleaned up we kind of just have been
moving stuff around and hiding all of
the mess one thing that we always do
have on hand bananas yeah this is this
is it this is behind the scenes
now you look here honey and who's a good
wittle' here do you love mommy do you
want to sit for mommy can you sit wait
[Music]
can you pull the brightness down a
little two days very long shooting
everyone has been great sports we ate a
lot of food a lot of pizza I think we're
all still recovering from yesterday's
pizza they're both at full brightness
yeah oh oh what was that what you just
do it's all it's all very much in
keeping him down yeah let's see what
that looks like some can you match that
I think so with this nice lamp yeah it's
good really good posture it might be I
don't think I'm ever actually gonna get
my house back because there is stuff
everywhere it's like look
you guys haven't yet seen the official
video I'll put a link in the description
and an annotation at the end to make
sure is go check that out but yeah this
is this is it hope you guys enjoyed the
video and are you snacking the one thing
that we always have on hand or play
[Music]
[Applause]